in our series a more perfect union
William to show you that what unites us
as Americans is far greater than what
divides us
today we're taking a trip down memory
lane to the day when jumpin double-dutch
was a go-to pastime for african-american
girls Niki batiste meets a woman who's
reintroducing the game and bringing
thousands of people together nationwide
this is more than just a street game for
most african-american girls growing up
in the 70s 80s and 90s double-dutch was
part of the culture this was back in the
day where we played outside while the
boys were playing basketball we were
jumping double-dutch jumping all day
until the street lights came on McDonald
even Fletcher with the jump rope
phenomenon in this 1981 commercial for
young black girls what did double-dutch
provide that other avenues didn't there
was like a sense of community because
girls would just get together and you
form friendships with sometimes you
don't even have to know the girls you
were jumping with because it was a
commonality that we all shared that
sense of community is what 49 year-old
Pamela Robinson reignited in suburban
Chicago with the 40-plus double-dutch
club we put on old school music and they
singing they're dancing we're talking
and it's just like old times
Robinson's idea was sparked by a tough
time in her own life for a long time I
wasn't really sure what my purpose was
I'm an empty nester and I'm going
through a divorce right now and so I
didn't know what my purpose were coz I
always felt like it was to be a great
wife and mother looking for a place to
forget her troubles
she started these weekly group meetups
in 2016 hoping to find others that love
that tapping sound as much as her there
have been women who have said yeah my
husband told me he wanted me to make
dinner but I said I got to go to
double-dutch I can make dinner when I
get home I
I'm not missing double-dutch you make
dinner or that right are you really
hungry the club now boasts over six
thousand members from all over the
country many of whom turned up last
month for the first annual double dutch
party and convention will you jump in I
don't have to do chores I'm in a place
where everything was simple it's clear
that for all these women this goes
beyond just jumping rope what does
double dutch give you that nothing else
can peace of mind peace of mind freedom
jump women meeting friends I love
caramel both
seize them Oh despite my own well
tangled up
double dutch debut I immediately felt
the camaraderie support and community
that just a few simple skips can bring
I'm bringing all of these women together
and they are loving not only each other
but the fact that they're getting
healthy and they're enjoying themselves
doing it and now you have thousands of
new friends I do I've got all these new
friends a time for friendship fitness
and funds for CBS this morning
Niki batiste Chicago this is so great
double dutch is a little girl that's so
nice
like Pamela Robinson or that bravado
Nikki booties we're trying I would look
like you Nikki even look that great